I wrote a book called push and the book
is about living according to your
priorities I live according to my
priorities in my contract was I'm not
doing appearances and I'm not traveling
I've got kids because of that when I
signed this book deal they were like
okay well we've lined up all of these
appearances for you and I'm like but the
book is about being home with your
family and how to align your priorities
and then they're like we've pushed your
book launch you're gonna have to do
appearances from December 15th to
January 15th like back to back to back
to back and I said I won't and I'm a
people pleaser so that was hard and
they're like you just need to understand
like you're probably not going to get
another book deal with us this is how
you move books you got to get on all the
podcasts and all the interviews and all
the shows and I'm like I'll use my email
list it's true I didn't get another book
deal with them but I did become a New
York time bestseller here's the part
that I'm proud of I didn't do any
interviews and I see people and they
just they destroy themselves doing like
all these interviews and they're on
everybody's podcast some people love
that it Strokes their ego or whatever
but I don't I'm an introvert I want to
stay home and I don't want to go
anywhere if that's you focus on your
email list and you do that by
understanding how to use your social to
funnel people there